boy where's my camera and that's and
that's why I'm in a restaurant in Vegas
your sister runs right Joe yeah
just stop yeah not a time for you I'm
just trying to get you a Rolex but what
am i what are you doing it's a fake
laughing if you're doing a high I'm
successful and so is he not so much hey
what the [ __ ] Joe just saying this is my
place sure and you're showing up a news
clip wearing my sweatshirt you're trying
to promote your brand with mine just
work out the Morning News
that's cashmere sweater yes that's a
[ __ ] Russell Athletic from dick take
it back - I'm not taking it back right
now get it you can't even fix that in
the color code what are you trying to
adjust the color
oh [ __ ] gray [ __ ] you [ __ ] Greg it's not
great tix brings out my eyes you don't
have eyes success Rome stands Oh what's
your [ __ ] restaurants where I can not
go dropped it's a registred joke yeah
it's amazing your sister what do I serve
you to clean ass Philippine no aye sir
if Japanese it's a booster it is that's
on my mind just say and if find funny
comes out of it the funny come like that
I made you and he did not make me no but
is what I learned from you is to not do
it you know I like that I molded you and
enrolled me at all if I did I broke it
because it was it was him thank
Christian are worn to you listen what I
mean is I like that you were in the nest
I was feeding my with some know and then
I let go and night when you grew
feathers I released you and that's what
I know where's my camera there's only
one camera by the way oh you're talking
it's a podcast I understand it just know
that if I want to shoot you out of the
sky they won't happen dude look
oh wow oh thank God for him huh
what you know I mean what do you know
what's listening to the kid right [ __ ]
if you really think about it your turn
if I really think about it if this
splits the show split yeah no one's
listening to the [ __ ] okay dude that's
about what five percent of the [ __ ] hey
you don't know that you know I have
metrics watch what happens I have
analytics where do you get those I know
someone here what's his name Korean guy
Koreans no other [ __ ] I'm just saying
Korea it's a good weight Chin's Korea
where's my camera to all my Korean
people you know you're not going no
thanks but no seriously they're already
thinking about the fighter pod does that
even that even flows good divider a lot
of cash pointer kid what who old news
bro what kidding myself sure right like
this pod is [ __ ] amazing like it
changed your life yes and and you know
and I'm happy for him because for years
nothing was happening for him hey know
that lots of things hangover yeah
nothing happened I think you're a man
yeah I was on man no one even knew it
gave up man that's the message we're
trying to say I don't think that's
amazing talented Fred it happens 65 -
Sophie - [ __ ] this is 65 this podcast
- Sara boy you don't know that 60 60 I
like I wouldn't want to kill myself
60 like not what am i doing with my life
that's not my sabbatical one I've earned
it all that's how I stop calling myself
the kid that's a hell of an old man
wearing hip clothes I'll [ __ ] talk
like that jo koy take it back what are
you doing right now
I saw this episode of who take you to
shirt off in boxing you gon roll the
tits no I don't you have old got a great
yes I'll take it back up he had old man
buff no I don't hold man Bob you've not
even seen me your eyes are glass Tovar
I'm looking at no I
it should be look me in the eye once I'm
just like a guy kid yeah I feel like I
feel like I would like Jo twice not like
my stock with Dupree why are you
laughing
mm oh that's a nice day yeah they change
it to deliver yes I can't I don't
perform in restaurants anymore well no
you you just did that
oh you does did that I know about it
years ago that was last season I saw you
doing a promo on Instagram hey get fish
and chips and see me live like the fish
come see all you can eat fish and chips
and comedy Thursday's with Bryan Callen
buy three tickets no buy one get one
free
come see the kid I don't like I don't
like any of this I don't like where this
look line & sinker
hook line and sinker comedy come see the
kid live nothing more depressed buy one
till you get 7 free just calm please
all-you-can-eat tartar sauce like any
went like that all-you-can-eat tartar
sauce tartar come see the other half of
fighter in the kid the kid the one
that's not as attractive why are you
white come on wait where's my camera got
me on this right you'll fight right yes
shingles - I have shingles stammers why
did you let me touch your knee I'll rub
why would you let me touch right here
plus my pustules on you I'll beat you up
and that'll give you shingles so don't
touch you and be a throw that's good you
can beat me up just don't touch I'm a
good-looking guy I didn't think about
you ever see Brad Pitt like what was
that movie where that he becomes old
dude like Benjamin Benjamin bar boy he
was good-looking and then he got a
little bit like mm yeah like I can see
like like you were you probably cute
when you're a kid and now say Oh like
[Music]
like this is my last one hey how would
you brought how would you describe
Brian's looks handsome tough Oh bright I
think no Brian Co yours yours out here a
joke what how would you describe Brian
go rough life rough life had a rough go
yeah yeah show shows in the face he
wears his he wears this problem was
right around his eyes Rogan Rogan and I
was talking and he goes we had a good
run
oh yeah yeah it's like what do you mean
he goes just you know now you know girls
if you were to date a younger girl the
girl would be like she'd tell her
friends and her friends who go it's true
no you're still good-looking
whatever I do you think so you're still
yeah yeah shingles a mile where's my
camera
sleepy I like the Suns in your eyes yeah
yeah this is my natural oh that's your
you just wake up in the morning what do
you look like waking up in the morning
Oh in the morning yeah oh wow you know
here here's a picture right here you see
the bottom right ages at the red eyes
[ __ ] no the red eyes hey that one
right there that's more like oh my god
Oh optical cavity is a [ __ ] Oh jumped
that's me oh man that's awesome
oh let's keep that I can tell I sound
like when I drop up when I when I come
dust where's my hat I don't know why
you're always looking for your hat he's
that was based on a
Ryan's life what huh the original it was
supposed to be Robin Williams stars in
Brian boldface Brian oh like you were no
don't say that
listen when you were in high school did
kids run up to you go what time's class
starts
I haven't young as you have a teacher
recently it's up until my eyes got
started falling yeah Oh Brian what do
you think Brian wants to get up like
surgery on his face no no just my eyes
my eyes are your eyes you don't want to
do that you look Asian no I'm not no
they look like you're sound good no
they're just gonna take a little skin to
fighting my baldness I just I just
shaved it good for you dude he I didn't
buy it's fighting the good fight my good
fine propecia the who do not I got a
hair transplant no you did not but not
but like nine years ago but it didn't
take let me see where he's hanging on to
do me they did like but it didn't work
for me
really so how did you touch it too much
I don't touch it too much shitty here I
don't want to do this how many touching
somebody that I you know me I really
love you man yeah you also hate him he's
always been I do hate okay I know it's a
weird relationship right can I tell you
why to oscillate okay
do you you know why I hate him cuz boys
he always makes promises and he breaks
them he can't keep what general can what
does that mean everyone you the whole
room what what do you mean provident
what about you make promises one example
you son of a [ __ ] you're spreading a
bad rumor no you always done that in the
community of comments well-known rumor
I'm seeing gigs for other people yeah
I'll give you a spot what time's your
show I'll come through
I've never ha what time you need me to
pick you up just anything that you with
response I'm never driving this you you
break you Yoram give me a comment of
podcasting would be called Brian Collins
how to burn bridges burn bridges the
burn bridges pop what have i burning the
bridges with a kid yeah oh that's it
burning bridges with the kids what did I
promise you that I didn't come through
on everything
what do we have for anything I've never
met coming up I have to ask you like hey
can I get some stage time on one of your
shows or and you're like oh my god would
love for you and then you would never
pick up my cause or that's a lie you're
me you're making a nice nothing that you
do I do opposite you're spreading
vicious bro I and that's why what I'm
successful and that's that should be
your infomercial why you want to be
successful
hi I'm Bryan Callen do you want to be
successful well then take my class
whatever I do
don't do it do everything opposite of
what I do and watch your money grow grow
grow you guys this is the don't do don't
do what I do remember I was in a
stressful pod called the fighter in the
kid and then I laugh now look at me bald
and bald NOT bald you [ __ ] old and bald
new eyes who are getting after the
special drops in June so Netflix special
drops in June what's it called uh we
haven't came up with a decision you know
no I'm poor man's Bryan Callen [ __ ]
burner just so hard just that rose
burning people I love that [ __ ] the
Asian poor-man's Brian care I'm going to
put subtitles so you can read it what
does that mean because you can't hear
anymore you're old you're an old man you
and I are the same basically right Bryan
Callen and I hope you enjoyed my car
with a terrible [ __ ] impression of me
bro I would I have funny stories that's
close that it's not close to I love
Porsche
hey so you're it you said in June
joe-joe Carly is it yeah oops I just
beat Michelle how do I sound what I'm
actually having sex before I die I just
[ __ ] again that is so disgusting
I know all right okay I feel
in Vegas man you go to my house oh you
live in Vegas yeah I live okay Joe
that's not you don't have to say it like
that don't it's so obnoxious but how
much is your mortgage I don't [ __ ]
know dude it's neither do I cuz I don't
have one that's crazy
they're all people all right dude all
right yeah I know
you came at me well no you did you're
like I'm like I asked you where if you
lived in Vegas yeah I live in baby all
right fine the ridges is it a big house
yeah it's huge okay dude I also said
that you favor keeping us locked down
for a year you having so much fun to
help what kind of hot is this I don't
know man we're seven told me no I know
hey you got a what do you have a Gucci
windbreaker okay man this and you now it
needs to stop but that out now it needs
a stop
you're dead serious man look at her what
are your shoes a coin purse no dude
they're not a cool study sort coins in
there hey is that a satchel you've had
that on grains
oh you ride your horse and then you feed
your horse with you you take your shoe
up there's grains oh say that huh these
are golden blue you can put water in
there you drink water all that yeah
there was that Carol is that a camel's
nutsack yeah they double as a [ __ ]
water bladder sure hey can I get a pair
of Converse that look like a stump from
a tree dude these are golden goose be
cool
they're moss green be cool they're
better than the way usually wears well
you know I will say this you I love you
know I love the way you think okay here
I love your thoughts man if your
thoughts were just your outfits huh
all right doesn't make sense it's more
later there's a lot of you know there's
a lot it was really full contact back
then I mean watch the documentary you
can see it there much thicker now though
right there no no all right can you not
participate in this particular
conversation you really that stupid come
is there by anyway we know why off his
microphone
we just talked to the fighter and shut
the kid up no I want to talk to sports
guy hold on dude please stop had the
greatest description of Michael Jordan
he goes if he had been on the Titanic it
wouldn't have sunk he would have been
plugging holes and [ __ ] running back
I think I think in the pod I think in
the pot after that and this is just some
direction yeah 40 seconds of complete
sorry okay slowly zoom into it's fun
right I'm trying to be part of the
conversation I don't think it doesn't
even make sense
plug the holes yes what is he the
fastest man on earth
I just mean he's got will too you know
we don't know stupid yeah every time
your son I've said it four times I
that's the fight just whatever I've
drawn he says that if I know I wanted
him to be like that's a great metaphor
and though he hated who you are though
who I know who you are you're the guy
like like at 98 you were well forty like
in 98 when you were 40 no you're a huge
Jordan fan yes you were
yes and and then slowly it became this
thing where you wanted to be against the
popular right because it's fun for Brian
well I seen Gabe I just didn't grow up
now all of a sudden he went from being a
huge fan in 98 to like who's the Michael
Jordan guy yeah now happen already
laying out reference for the Michael
Jordan full name alright they see a
black guy that's not how I talk man you
play baseball Michael Jordan all this
[ __ ] is intact
alright listen you do good job take it
with you scare to you so I'm not scared
of you so take it easier let me explain
something let me at least learn Tina's
weight a bunch I know a lot but Joe may
because you were next when we were when
we were in I was at the Malibu chili
cook-off that chili thing he was trying
to walk around his family all the
Chili's hundred of a hundred hold on
no can't move forward after that it's a
famous I don't be you don't go the MAL
malibu chick don't put me and go there
like this you know the chilly
what oh you what the [ __ ] why fade you
had money no don't do that don't train
you called yourself an elite I did not
show you that and you said the common
cattle he was it my audience but be real
Adam suddenly got swamped I really I'm
saying that's why I'd love to see one
James Corden start singing with him it's
great has James Corden sing yeah same
thing
yeah him you know that that's why show
so big he and sinks it I didn't know he
could say wow I gotta watch that show
roster here we go again
did you hear did you hear Brian breath I
gotta see that I got a watch alright
it's like your little digs bro with the
shoes the Michael Jordan guy is that I'm
sorry I'm not an elite Oh George
James Corbin all right dude yeah educate
educate yourself oh yeah I'll get I'll
give it a look look I'll get a look I
got you'll see kitty kitty see it's the
hottest segment bring him up let me hear
him say [ __ ] you come on oh he can see
I've been on unnecessary lockdown of
really famous cuz use a Broadway guy
using Book of Mormon now you just gotta
educate yourself on like the world yeah
yeah I don't know about you sometimes
right what are you why are you looking
at me with my shoes are these you cut in
your eyes having air jordans which
number those probably the Aviators
you're a really good actor thank you
buddy I've always said that about you
have I not yeah I've always said you're
a great actor I like when he gets off
stage I'm like you're a great actor I
tried though it's understand of state
you're great at when you [ __ ] her you
read those lines good on no I thought
you were coming he always goes to the
club like a scrip soften me up and then
you [ __ ] you give it
they'd be have that guy who's okay
that's great oh wow
went from a friend an [ __ ] real quick
from flower I thought we had a thing we
are I thought we had a thing where we do
this I know I know every time the show
starts you okay we got that thing right
where we're gonna I apologize yeah here
I'll call it the fighter that way I
apologize I apologize all ready there I
know I'm just saying you're gonna be
fine though you know you'll be fine
those things yeah I know take it easy
but that's not how I wanted this to go
no one did man no because when they do
that they do that for a long time right
you have to wear your nails that long
for like two three weeks right yeah
usually I will you let me talk just one
pocket on there let your [ __ ] guests
talk I'm sorry shut the [ __ ] I was
looking at that you go thank you God
Spyder sorry
and the cool no come on man now we know
we learned something more you know I'll
come on man no I didn't you know that
Mart
no don't smart right high Q what you're
always smarter than I recycle be taller
imbeciles caught you infants
oh yeah infants infants my favorite is
you're smart you uh you're a bit of a
fan favorite I'll give you that much
well I think the people like you cannot
massage the bottom of your thigh
whatever do that I pushed it yeah I
pushed and pulled away hey which is
right here okay now listen you're kind
of a hold a weighted slam salmon come on
where's my chapstick there yo buddy it
really turns everything turns very
southern hey man hey man I ever tell you
hey man we ever tell you come on it's a
family show dude it's a family you're so
disrespectful what else yeah dude
this is covered your paint and your
[ __ ] what do you learned or like you
know I mean like you know like Steven I
smell sorry you're the one that's
talking about giving him knives you got
me at night whatever the [ __ ] it get
this [ __ ] leather shoes I made of
leather shoes at a craft
it's just favorite kind of being a dick
how I did Rosie get that shirt no it's
not good cut it out cut it out
hey did you get the elk jerky jerky I
got it for one of that shove me dude
with our legit long turned off damn it
Joe I swear to God I didn't give it all
right now I'm my super ace right this is
Brian as the Japanese [ __ ] super
stereotypical that's Bobby doing it
that's Bobby Lee doing hey you're gonna
have to put subtitles on it cuz I'm not
gonna move my lips today you go that's a
fairy oh but you like it inside huh yeah
you're laughing it real quick yeah you
ever say hey let's look at an old
picture of somebody and that little
picture is a young pitcher of somebody
but when you go hey can we see an old
picture Brian and you look at an old
picture Brian and it's it's just him
fold
you know man like even what he's you
know no I mean like let's see an old
picture
Brian was
there's a lot out there but certain
shoes like specially dunks dunks are
like right now done sb dunks are like
the hot what our dunks did you see the
shoes time why do you act like this why
do you ruin every conversation oh you
just ruin every girl why you're like my
dad be cool
the second ones in the Valentine's Day
lunch those are dope Papa just got those
that's cool
I swear you're so annoying why I'm sure
dope those are sick by the way those are
all I got I got a hook you up with my
got your and uh I'll pass I don't know
that's in San Antonio but boy Jake does
custom shoes for LeBron Beckham
everybody he brought me custom custom
supreme ones low tops show him those
chin Brian go get us something [ __ ]
no I want to be part of this oh I love
some fresh kicks you know what I hate
the most is like this would be such a
great conversation yeah you're ruining
I'm not doing anything out you're
ruining old I'm listening you're being
very old no I'm not I'm saying it's like
fresh and dodo those are small there's a
sicko he makes them for Nike he make he
gets the all the the all the the
materials are from where Nike gets
theirs oh really
and just refurbished is the whole thing
does its own style oh this is so good
I'm really rich
like I really detail how do they get
that dope you're annoying Wow Wow get
back on set bro I'm literally just
sitting here as an actor as a working
actor then time offer you how much say
all right again how long does it take
you to remember your three lines in that
show no first of all like three look
that's a [ __ ] anything mistakes I'm the
star and also I have a photographic
memory
yeah and no one believed that that's why
we're not completely July it I remember
the internet shut down you know what my
new goal is dead serious shut up I'm not
shutting the [ __ ] up please
shot in the [ __ ] up but I'm not taking
myself seriously yeah no more at all no
I don't
at all III know dude it starts to you
know you really need fish oil for those
joints right but your joint no that
wasn't a point that what you're getting
here
no I open myself up and now you guys are
being fixed about my eight I know you
gave me a really nice compliment about
how yeah and then he went right to your
knees and how how you don't have time
the time is limited now cuz your your on
the other side now the back you're on
the other side though yeah you're coming
down the hill then come back now you
know what else to expect a lot of time
climbing up that hill but now you're
[ __ ] don't you're rolling out
thanks oh yes I'm gonna have all the
others I'm gonna have my day have your
day bro you're called back all this said
yeah but I'm just not sound like thirty
thousand tickets Amin okay no you're not
well actually that's just the two shows
in San Francisco if you add up the whole
weekend it's close to what we figure out
you ahead 60,000 okay all right Joe I'm
trying to sell it the West Palm Beach
improv this weekend I'll be there for
Valentine's Day Friday Saturday
something I'm [ __ ] quitting stamp how
many times have I asked you to come to
my show
to be honest I've asked you so many
times to come to my show
you mean yours to come on my show to go
to go up and perform I've asked you and
I I've asked Brett you call calm him
once
let me come to a tight hour I don't give
a [ __ ] that's not what I want from you
okay you just you just I want to keep
them there I want to contain them yeah
because you want even though the whole
goal yeah man the whole goal is to keep
them in there for a certain amount of
time give them a [ __ ] show yeah so
you would go in there three like salt
pepper like a little three four minutes
you know whatever your best no no it's
something do I fly up myself and the
night note fly you I got a private jet
you got like oh you're like ten open
seats but like but uh so generous I'm
just joking by the way you know that
right dead serious thanks Joe well you
know what that's my camera which one's
my that was the only way if you had
worked on in your face cuz you look
tight no no it's that's Asian so like
what do you have Asian ji
yeah you don't get that many lines
across the forehead right so yours is
like like a tree like when you cut a
tree you count I say to the tree so
shitty degree there's like seven rings
take your piece of every ring is 10
years sure yeah so that's like I say
it's more like a packet of Bakker don't
have a pack of bacon yeah yeah say that
about my face man I'm wearing makeup so
the the 11 okay so you know when you cut
a tree yes and you see the Rings I hate
this you can't count how old the tree is
and buy the Rings I know you said you
like when you like like raise your
eyebrows no just raise your eyebrows no
that's a black surprise real quick like
look up look up wow that each line is
like seven years no it's not how did you
can count 10 don't what is 7 times 6 I'm
bad at math it's like 79 or 42 40
there's the other thing so then that's
wrong yeah yeah that's wrong it must be
do it again one more time
fine I'm gonna do it again but don't I
won't know you know me I'm not shitty
come on oh you forgot the line in the
middle of his eyebrows Hey so 7 times 8
is 56 your your head is like dog ears
each line is like 7 years
can't say my face to tree and like dog
ears you can't say that there's 8 lines
across your head there's times that by 7
7 times 8 is what yeah if I get my times
8 is what right 7 times 8 5650 and how
old are you I'm 53 boom Brian Brian
Brian slingback Yuna's lids done though
yeah are you yeah we've talked about I
can't see well I've aged that's the
difference between 49 and 53 that Riley
you can't see my eyes yeah it's like he
has a visor over both eyes now and it's
from years of boxing sports well it's
father our [ __ ] office it's fine
still [ __ ] by the way and I [ __ ] I
[ __ ] well yeah dudes well who knows
but here's my question you still [ __ ] oh
look at you blank face huh I was in Tel
you know
I don't know now you're a prude look at
you I don't want to talk about that with
you you just smile you've just swallowed
with your mouth open you wet you can't
even answer man you might be a phony
sixty thousand tickets my ass
are you dip no no no that's real though
you should have seen the deposit I made
today and if you want to challenge me on
a bet no I'll pull it out I brought my
back man no just in case I don't know
hold for all it you want to go wallet
for wallet Oh since you were bragging
about that goddamn TV set you got to get
to know but that's it we were getting
coffee Brent were you right next to me
Brandon when he said that yeah you did
it goes through I gotta hurry let's get
this pot I got to get to the TV set if
you I'll a pretty long lap car both want
to do it do you want to settle the bet
wallet for wall all right that's so
gauche now I'm just saying I have a
Noblet for money you can challenge that
or you can go with the deposit slips I
did Sam triple everyone I got [ __ ]
cash on me - Cakebread yeah but I have a
lot I'm awesome so I was I was I was
blessed in high school you were athletic
really good-looking so I never had any
problems and I was funny how crazy your
hair was thinning in your face was
always old does that so big that's a
fair thing I saw a baby picture of your
face take it back and usually well
usually babies have a lot of wrinkles
and they go he'll grow into it yeah cuz
it's loose skin yeah you've never grown
into it you still have the wrinkles
there yeah it's such a jerk to me right
now I would stop sunbathing
I don't son I would stop sunbathe I stay
out of the Sun I'm on set all day that's
that small soundstage in front of your
lights lights lights lights like um well
this is uh I'm really uh jealous of your
success hey your beaks are casually like
camera a pet not laughing of sad day hey
hope yours you're being a jerk dude I'm
proud of my [ __ ] teen Oh baby oh I
love your show it's very funny your cast
is amazing Tim come on Tim is amazing
why don't you come get your app already
be this last week for more episodes best
OH oh we like
- you said this is last week you know
that is true he did say that no I said
you don't know I was doing show puppy
bandwagon I remember that yeah I
remember you saying that and you're like
this is my Latin yeah you know I know
Lila you're doing a good thing
Wow did you study kind of day yeah I
studied cut up I didn't know that yeah
that was clearly a [ __ ] I am I mean I
study and I know the difference yeah let
me see your fist we need a yo oh there's
there's a lot of cuts and you trained I
trained secretly yeah Wow I'll fight man
what as long as there's sharp objects or
glass around you're down I'm gonna use
it if I come at you ask a Chicago diner
15 years ago
what happened so if I come at you I'll
throw something at your [ __ ] face
well what's crazy is your face is made
of leather No so wha no you've been you
don't cut you've been mean about you
don't cut okay I bleed just like
everybody else
yes I do I bleed just like everybody
else and I cry and and I you ever tried
tear leather in half you know you can't
impossible that's your face no no that's
your face you're being where's my camera
you're being so rude a enemy is it the
small one
yeah it's the big one it's the big one
no the big one okay man wealth has made
you such a jerk - doctor it's your lungs
pee now I'm gonna die oh really yeah you
[ __ ] do we go to break no keep going no
you and I you know I kind of connect
like yeah yeah yeah we're actually it's
actually probably better the fighter in
the koi that's right but yeah uh fighter
in the koi well there's a K already
there can you record that can you record
that yeah I want this documented there's
already a K so the fighter in the koi
kind of flows so do your set bro which
one's my camera right which one's the
camera start before you guys do this can
I ask Brian a serious question and don't
get it don't get mad at me don't be
shitty um well have I been yes very much
so
worst of all time now now be nice what
we can ask I'm just gonna ask you okay
have you memorized your line
the one line Joe that's a shitty you're
being you're being a dick and your fake
sucking that right now you know who's on
roids
oh no I'm not don't nod to me like that
don't spread rumors about me just cuz
I'm naturally muscular Leatherface oh no
Joe coming Leatherface do you have a
picture of their face gosh I could pull
it up pull up pull up leather face and
tell me this is it Bryan Callen
just like waking up in the morning
that's up right Kalin no that's not
right early in the morning no no before
you put on kind of moisturizer oh that's
so bright there I bought that mask
before on Halloween it's not the Bryan
Callen
that's called the Bryan Callen right
there there's a new doctor is it Netflix
the the mr. rinks stealing [ __ ] jokes
and I talked about doing a TV show we
sold them sell search they say rah rah
rah rah rah rah rah rah
hey you bro you [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah yeah
watch your tongue oh good what's gonna
happen what are you gonna do use some of
that boxing you've been doing
[Laughter]